happy Easter everyone some great news to
start off the Paschal season Tennessee
lawmakers have voted to expel two of
their Democrat colleagues from the State
House of Representatives after those
colleagues shut down the legislative
session and led a mob across the house
floor to intimidate lawmakers there was
a third Democrat legislator who was
involved but her behavior was slightly
less obscene than that of the other two
so she was able to survive the expulsion
motion by a single vote still pretty
good news though right democracy defeats
the unruly mob everyone should be happy
but one vice president Kamala Harris is
not
they were channeling
understand that and is that not what a
democracy allows
a democracy says you don't silence the
people you do not stifle the people you
don't turn off their microphones when
they are speaking about the welcome of
life and Liberty
that is not what the Democracy does so
first of all that is literally what a
democracy does Tennessee lawmakers acted
entirely within their rights actually
within their obligations as duly elected
representatives to expel the people who
tried to undermine the Democratic
process second Kamala Harris gave that
speech in Nashville
nice to see she finally remembered where
Tennessee is
the administration couldn't be bothered
to show up after a trans-identifying
shooter targeted and murdered six people
including children at a Christian
Elementary School in the lead-up to
Easter but now that Democrats lost some
seats for trying to overthrow the state
house now Kamala remembers how to get to
Nashville interesting third though
haven't Kamala and her crew been telling
us for two years now that disrupting
legislative sessions is the worst crime
imaginable in our sacred democracy that
it's an Insurrection that threatens
everything we hold dear and that's just
when regular people are doing it forget
about when the legislators themselves
are doing it
usually it's Democrats who are actually
rioting of course in which case that's a
wonderful expression of democracy of
course it's absurd of course it's a
double standard but calling out
hypocrisy and a three or four bucks in
Biden's economy we'll get you a cup of
coffee it used to be a buck 50 but
inflation has made it tough calling out
hypocrisy is how conservatives are going
to pass the time when the Liberals
finally haul us off to the gulags the
great news here
is that Republicans are wielding
political power against their opponents
in a just prudent and Swift way
Republicans around the rest of the
country should take note this
is how you deal with liars and Bullies
great job Tennessee I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show The Mob is
getting really really crazy there was a
mob that violently attacked Riley Gaines
who is a young female athlete speaking
out against the transgender Madness and
she was pummeled over at San Francisco
State we'll get to that in just a little
bit first though speaking of mobs did
you see the story out of Texas this is
probably the most egregious miscarriage
of Justice I've seen in at least three
or four hours now I don't know they keep
coming pretty rapidly army Sergeant
Daniel Perry
he's a guy who
was driving his car minding his own
business back in 2020 he found himself
surrounded by BLM rioters and a BLM
rioter was carrying an AK-47 pointing
that AK-47 at Daniel Perry at his car
and as the Riders killed dozens of
people this man is being threatened
directly with a weapon with a pretty
pretty serious rifle and so Daniel Perry
defended himself and shot
the man who was pointing the gun at him
open and shut case right and this is
Texas too which is a pretty reasonable
state so initially it was all fine
then a George soros-backed district
attorney took over and decided to pursue
charges against a man for defending
himself against an unruly mob that was
pointing a gun at him
then that district attorney Jose Garza
decided to at least according to David
fujit who is a lead investigating
detective in the case gorz had decided
to ignore exculpatory evidence of Perry
decided to suppress that exculpatory
evidence of Perry
decided that he was going to do whatever
he can to put the innocent man the guy
was protecting himself Behind Bars to
defend the violent Terror mob of black
lives matter
obviously
Perry needs to be pardoned
and Governor Abbott down there in Texas
has said that Perry will receive a full
pardon the first moment that the request
comes across his desk
that's good
I want to see it though
I don't want to hear just promises I
don't want this thing to be dragged out
we need a absolute full pardon I think
there should be a full pardon for
anybody any normal person who has been
targeted by these Soros prosecutors
because don't forget there's two sides
to the story of the soros-backed
prosecutors George I know we're not
allowed to say it because we don't the
Democrats don't want us to open the
curtain on their political strategy but
George Soros is one of the most
influential Democratic donors he's given
a ton of money over the years and he
remains very very active in Democrat
politics and in recent years he's
pursued a particular strategy of funding
prosecutors in cities with the express
intent of letting ordinary criminals off
the hook
but then the flip side to that is
Prosecuting conservatives
you let the leftists who commit actual
crimes you let them off the hook you you
find the conservatives who are just
being normal and opposing the left and
you try to throw them behind bars
and you've seen the consequences of this
broader move within the criminal justice
system in recent years the doj is going
to go after parents who don't want their
kids to get Trans in elementary school
the OJ is going to go after Catholics
who go to mass on Sunday the OJ is going
to go after pro-lifers who are
peacefully protesting and who are saying
prayers outside of abortion clinics
meanwhile they're going to let murderers
off the hook they're going to let
millions of illegal aliens who come into
the country they're going to completely
let them off the hook they're going to
let terrorists BLM that burns the
country down for eight months going to
let them off the hook
that's the flip side and so what what
the conservatives need to do is not just
point out the hypocrisy not just point
out the double standard we have to do
something about it
it's not rocket science okay you don't
need an advanced degree in political
science
the libs are going after the innocent
people and they're they're letting the
criminals off the hook we need to
reverse that and we need to wield the
power we got so absolutely Governor
Abbott pardon this man fully then let's
go further let's start Prosecuting BLM
let's go further let if the libs can
prosecute Trump for a non-crime that he
allegedly committed seven years ago I
think we can prosecute the leftists who
were marauding and raping and pillaging
and killing just three years ago don't
you think we can do that I think we can
then we got to go further we need to
recognize that in this bifurcated system
of justice there are political prisoners
there are dissidents who are being
persecuted by this regime and where
we've got the power we got to let them
off the hook and we need to go after the
genuine bad guys okay things are getting
a little crazy out there
in the political order and the justice
system especially in the economy it's
why you got to check out Birch gold
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98
Robert Kiyosaki the author of the
best-selling book Rich Dad Poor Dad has
just cautioned that the world economy is
on the verge of collapse warning of Bank
runs Frozen savings and bail-ins He
suggests that you quote buy real gold
and silver coins now and this volatile
Market diversification has never been
more important that is why buying gold
with Birch gold is such a smart choice
the government spending is out of
control long-term bonds have diminished
in value which is crippling banks
depositors are holding their breath and
investors are bailing on Bank stocks you
cannot spend your way out of inflation
gold is a tangible asset with a reliable
store of value because it's not tied to
any one economy or currency it can be a
safe haven in times of Crisis Birch gold
will help you convert an existing Ira or
401K into a tax sheltered Ira in
physical precious metals like gold and
silver it is time to start thinking
about your investments in your future
you need to consider diversifying into
gold with Birch gold text Knowles kwles
298 9898 to claim your free info kit on
gold today and talk to a precious metals
expert that is Knowles to 98 98 98.
speaking of guilty verdicts president
Trump has been indicted now he's been
indicted for this non-crime that he
committed seven years ago which in my
view does not even come close to rising
to the level of misdemeanor but and it's
a very novel legal theory that suggests
that it would even be a misdemeanor but
then even more absurd the prosecutor in
New York Alvin Bragg is trying to argue
that this is a felony he's not even
explaining how this could be a felony
and all of that's silly but it doesn't
mean that they won't convict Trump in
fact Alan dershowitz who has been a
lawyer for president Trump he's been on
this show he's one of the leading legal
Minds in the country Harvard law
professor emeritus he says
he thinks Trump is going to be found
guilty
I don't think I could get this case
dismissed so easily I don't think that I
don't think that that had the best
of the world Abraham Lincoln and John
Marshall a New York City judge would
dismiss this case because that New York
City judge's life would be over
everybody would point to him the way
they pointed to me when I defended oh my
God there's the man who helped jump get
free so I don't think it's going to be
easy I think he probably will be
convicted by a New York and jury who
voted for Bragg and voted for get trump
it will be reversed on appeal it will
never be affirmed all the way up to the
Supreme Court but uh brag's going to be
popular he'll be re-elected uh and and
and he'll probably win his case unless
unless there is a change venue
uh Alan dershowitz is almost certainly
right he's usually right about these
things so you say okay well at least
Trump will get off the hook when it's
appealed
okay is he
he's kind of long in the tooth okay he's
a young vibrant man certainly in his
behavior but he's he's not that young
and even forget about the time scale of
Hit the rest of his life what about the
time scale of a campaign how long before
this thing first of all comes to a
guilty verdict then gets appealed then
maybe goes up to the Supreme Court it's
gonna be long after the presidential
election so what matters is not what
happens eventually what matters is what
happens over the next 18 months
so
putting that aside for a second
putting the legal aspect aside this
continues to be the best argument for
the Trump campaign
in a way this is a win-win it's a win
for Alvin Bragg the D.A because he knows
that he needs to go after Trump to get
reelected he ran on on going after Trump
so he's got to go after him to get
reelected even if it'll be overturned
even if it's legally ridiculous but then
two
this is great for Trump's campaign
because the the best argument for
Trump's campaign is not that he's
necessarily got the best policies he's
got great policies and he succeeded at
bringing about some great policies as
president he had some Clunkers in there
too so it's a mixed bag and the other
candidates are untested so so they can
make the case that they would have
better policy it's not that Trump hires
the best people we know that Trump
himself would say no I've had some real
losers in there in my crew
it's not that Trump has the most even
temperament
Trump has a very Charming personality
that has served him well for 40 years
but he's turned a lot of people off too
the argument for Trump
is
that if the libs hate him this much
that they would go to unprecedented
lengths to stop him from being elected
then he must be the best choice
that's the whole argument for the Trump
campaign
that's the argument that the other
candidates can't make
Governor DeSantis can say I'm the better
version of trump I'm putting all these
great policies forward in Florida he can
make a very plausible argument for all
of that the one special
bonus that Trump has over not just
DeSantis but all the other candidates is
he can say yeah but they're going after
me the hardest
so while the while the other campaigns
will spin that and say yes see we have a
better shot of getting elected
Trump is going to say yeah but they're
going after me the hardest they're going
to Historic
unprecedented lengths to arrest the
president they're arresting a former
president and current leader of the
opposition
they're probably going to do it three
times before this campaign is over
that tells you exactly why it's got to
be me
I'm not saying that's a persuasive
argument I'm just telling you that is
the argument for the campaign and it's
the best argument that I've heard so far
for the re-election of trump so what are
the Republicans doing about it I'm
really pleased to say you know we're so
down especially on the Republicans a lot
of the time because they're so spineless
but the Republicans seem to be growing a
spine this is a nice start to the Easter
season
you're seeing now House Republicans
moving to go after the prosecutors in
this case and especially Jim Jordan who
is just absolutely terrific there was
some talk that Jim Jordan maybe could
become the speaker of the house when the
conservative Wing didn't want McCarthy
and the more moderate Wing didn't want
any of the freedom caucus people and Jim
Jordan's name was floated as someone who
would be acceptable to all sides and and
Jim just said no I don't want it I don't
want it stop trying to make me be
speaker of the house I want to stay on
Judiciary that's where my expertise is
That's where I've got a plan to do
things don't give me the worst job in
Washington and people finally respected
his decision well now we see why we want
Jim Jordan on Judiciary Jim Jordan has
decided to subpoena Manhattan prosecutor
who resigned because the D.A Alvin Bragg
initially said he would not prosecute
Trump
so what's this about this is a warning
shot to Alvin Bragg this is a warning
shot saying be very careful of how you
proceed here because we're going to come
after you and we're going to come after
the people around you and we're going to
dig up all the dirt on how malicious and
transparently partisan this prosecution
of trump is and we're going to bring in
a guy who was impelling you to do it at
first and he's going to air all that
dirty laundry and he's he's got no
reason not to do it because he already
resigned
how is Congress going to do this
wouldn't you say well this is this is a
matter for the States you hypocrite
conservatives I thought you respected
states rights and federalism and
subsidiarity let New York do what New
York wants to do well here's the legal
argument for it
According to Jim quote Congress has a
specific and manifestly important
interest in preventing politically
motivated prosecutions of current and
former presidents
by state and local prosecutors
particularly in jurisdictions like New
York County where the prosecutor is
popularly elected and trial level judges
lack life tenure she was saying this is
just an aspect of democratic politics
which obviously the Congress has some
interest in and they especially have an
interest when these prosecutions are
against
president when they're against people
from the federal government this is a
really really great move and I hope this
is just the very first warning shot
for the Republicans to say
we're done we're done with this we're
done being held to a an incoherent
standard by the left that the left does
not recognize we're done conceding and
rolling over and only playing defense a
defensive strategy that has not defended
anything no we're going to start playing
real hard ball politics and we'll do it
in a just way and we'll do it within the
bounds of the law but we're going to do
it okay so when you come in and you try
to disrupt our legislative session one
of those Tennessee three as they're
calling them from one of these radical
leftist Democrat lawmakers who led the
mob into the actual legislative session
and tried to disrupt the proceedings
that guy had been arrested
just a few years ago as as a protester
as one of the activists going in
assaulting the speaker of the Tennessee
house okay these guys are absolute
miscreants they have no business in the
legislature and the Tennessee
Republicans are saying yeah you're out
well we'll we'll call you racist okay
cool what we'll call you I don't know
what other insults do we have um phobic
okay sure you okay call me whatever you
want Sticks and Stones can break my
bones but your lies will not hurt me and
they will not prevent me from pursuing
my political agenda
Jim Jordan oh you're gonna go after
Trump and you're going to pretend this
is within the bounds of law okay I think
we're going to subpoena the guys around
you we're going to figure out what this
is really about and then we're going to
go after you Mr Bragg and we are not
going to roll over any more
now speaking of controversial people
being interviewed Alyssa heinershide you
probably haven't heard that name before
Alyssa heinershud no relation to my own
sweet little Elisa very different women
uh Alyssa heinershit is the VP of
marketing at Bud Light
and here is Alyssa heinershide
explaining
why Bud Light has gone trans
I'm a businesswoman I had a really clear
job to do when I took over Bud Light and
it was this brand is in Decline it's
been in Decline for a really long time
and if we do not attract
young drinkers to come and drink this
brand there will be no future for Bud
Light so I had this super clear mandate
it's like we need to evolve and Elevate
this incredibly iconic brand and my what
I brought to that was a belief in okay
what is what what does evolve and
elevate mean it means inclusivity it
means Shifting the tone it means having
a campaign that's truly inclusive and
feels lighter and brighter and different
and appeals to women and to men and
representation is it sort of the heart
of evolution
so you see she's using Market language
you're saying look the brand is in
Decline it's all these old men drinking
Bud Light which I don't think is true by
the way I think primarily people who
drink Bud Light are fried Stars it's
true that older
like construction workers and guys at
baseball games that's that's a little
bit of an older crowd but it's mostly
frat guys as far as I'm concerned and
young college kids but okay and she says
so the way to look we just have to do it
to evolve the brand and the way to do it
is to appeal to women and men you know
women and men who famously love
transvestitism right uh dude I don't
think they do but keep going people who
reflect you in the work and we had this
hangover I mean Bud Light had been
people who reflect you yeah nothing
reflects me like Dylan Mulvaney people
who reflect point one percent of the
population yeah yeah I I finally feel
seen now I can drink Bud Light because a
man dressed up as Audrey Hepburn who who
is a Broadway musical star yeah he
that he just really represents me in
kind of a brand of
out of touch humor and it was really
important that we had another approach
so she admits she goes it's just these
old people who do it but and but but and
that's why Bud Light was mostly a fratty
kind of brand well people who are in
fraternities are not
old they tend to be pretty young and
they said this is out of touch humor no
you know what's much funnier
zealous ideological liberals yeah we're
just we're known for our humor oh yeah
all the stand-up comedians yeah they're
known for how that much they all love
political correctness that's what makes
a successful comedian right I don't
think so since we we have to appeal to
the people
and the way to do that is through
transgenderism according to Pew research
60 percent of Americans say that a
person's gender is determined by his
biological sex his sex assigned at Birth
by the way sixty percent that's the
majority of Americans that's not a
decline it's not like it used to be 80
and now it's 60 It's actually an
increase just over the last two years in
2021 it was only 56 percent who said
that in 2017 it was only 54 who said it
so transgenderism is less accepted today
than it was two years ago
and much less accepted today than it was
six years ago the plurality of Americans
say that Society has gone too far
advancing transgender rights
so there are different views about this
but the largest number of people
who have any view on transgenderism
according to Pure research which is a
very respected polling firm or a very
respected Research Institute
says that
we've gone too far we need to roll back
the quote-unquote transgender rights of
which there are none by the way because
transgenderism is a false anthropology
so it's just it's wrong about human
nature and Wrongs cannot be right that's
why they call them rights so this isn't
about helping the company adapt to the
culture that's not what this is about
this is about
as it always is forcing the culture
to adapt to leftism
through the companies
she's making this disingenuous Market
argument look it's just about adapting
to Changing Times no you people are
forcing The Changing Times by grabbing
up a lot of political power and then
wielding it
against the desires of the people be
they
through the Democratic process or be
they through the market
now
speaking of the market what if I told
you you could really really help fix
your company's finances well you can do
that with ramp right now go to ramp.com
do you want a better way to simplify
your business finances across expenses
vendor payments and accounting if so
ramp could be a complete game changer
for your business ramp is a corporate
card and expense management software
designed to help you save time and money
with ramp you can issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
and automate expense reporting so you
can stop wasting time at the end of
every month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to the time you'll
save each month on employee expenses
will allow you to close your books eight
times faster businesses that use ramp
save an average of three and a half
percent within the first year ramp is
easy to use get started in less than 15
minutes whether you have five employees
or five thousand right now you can get
two hundred fifty dollars when you join
ramp just go to ramp.com Knowles that is
ramp.com slash Knowles cards issued by
Sutton Bank at Celtic Bank members FDIC
terms and conditions apply I know what
you're thinking you're thinking Michael
ah
how do you get your hair so shiny and
voluminous and spectacular
well the answer is Jeremy's Razor's
shampoo and conditioner that's right
Jeremy's razors is more than just a
razor company fighting to protect your
values it is also a Men's Grooming brand
that doesn't hate men and this quaff
that you see here is fortified every
morning thanks to Jeremy's tea tree and
Argan Oil infused shampoo and
conditioner but that's not all Jeremy's
also has
exfoliating charcoal body wash made with
hydrating aloe vera Eucalyptus in just
the right amount of pomegranate you
don't want too much pomegranate in your
charcoal body wash okay the men's care
products you see here are made with
natural ingredients they're 100 sulfate
free paraben free woke free and made
right here in the good old us of a head
on over to Jeremy's racers.com to kick
woke companies out of your bathroom
today
now speaking of leftist identity
politics
John leguizama
fairly well-known actor John Leguizamo
will not watch the Mario movie he has
come out against the Mario movie
why
because
there aren't any Latinos in it
the Latin character like I I was
groundbreaking then they stopped the
groundbreaking I know but we'll get
messed up they messed up the inclusion
they disincluded I don't right so what
do you say to people yeah you know who
might actually go out and support this
should you say hey guys if you stand for
inclusion maybe
catch some Latin folks we're 20 of the
population the largest people of color
group and we're
underrepresented over representing the
worst kind of jobs though oh I know
right right right right yeah sure so no
Super Mario Brothers for you hell no
hell no they didn't make Mario Mexican
so I
I don't know who needs to hear this
I think maybe John Leguizamo is the only
person who needs to hear this
Mario is an Italian
Mario is not Mexican or Salvadoran or
Peruvian or Argentine he's
his whole character
is that he is Italian
so if you boycott the Mario movie
because they didn't cast a Mexican
[Music]
as an Italian
you're just saying you hate white people
and Italians aren't even that white they
are the least white of the white people
they are a racially liminal ethnically
ambiguous
part of whatever makes up white people
you know what it is to quote sill from
The Sopranos it's anti-italian
discrimination
and it's anti-white discrimination just
generally it's this argument that yeah
we don't like white people we don't want
white people to play even the white
people roles
we only want non-white people to play
the white people roles and if any white
person dares play a non-white role we're
going to call that blackface or brown
face and we're going to ruin your life
and we're going to take away your career
Mario is Italian
Mario is it we're now at the we're now
at the stage of society
where it is controversial to say babies
are people
men are not women
and Mario and Luigi
are Italian
now speaking of
second part of that
identity Mayhem that we're living
through right now Riley Gaines Riley
Gaines you know her Young
College athlete
speaking out against the transgender
agenda meaning a lot of pushback we all
meet pushback when we talk out about
that
she was just violently attacked at San
Francisco State so Riley Gaines
shoes she was escorted out of her speech
cops
pulling her away from your mom
what they what they did was they tripped
the lights during her speech so she was
unprotected no one could really see her
the mom people start punching her in the
head hitting her
and then these
furiously
demon resembling maniacs
start chase her into a room and start
yeah you're crying you see word you b
word
trans
and then they they locked her in that
room she was stuck in that room for
three hours
why couldn't the cops just start beating
these people down these violent
agitators why couldn't the cops just at
least pull out their billy clubs and
just start beating them into submission
I don't know
I I don't know what are the cops there
for they they brought Riley into the
room to protect her but when there is a
violent mob that has already been
inflicting violence on a poor young
woman that's when the cops are supposed
to get violent too against the people
who instigated the violence
that's the point of having cops
I don't even totally blame the officers
they know what's going to happen
they know the minute
that they in any way use their just
authority to stop a and a current threat
a current violent action from a
protected class like the so-called
transgender people they know their life
is over and they're not only going to
lose their jobs they're going to be
prosecuted
it raises the question when you see a
video like that which doesn't even show
the first assault because they shut the
lights off in the room when they started
attacking her it raises this question
why is this group so particularly
violent
I've been in and around politics for a
pretty long time I worked my first
campaign when I was 19 years old first
first national campaign and
we've run afoul of all sorts of leftist
groups
there are all sorts of little leftist
activist groups the feminists the
environmentalists the this group to that
group
and they all get kind of feisty I can
just tell you firsthand
the violence and the threats and the
reaction from the transgender activists
it's on a completely different level
it's almost different in kind rather
than degree why is that
we all know
we all know even though I know we're not
allowed to say it on big Tech
why is it that this group of people
tends to be so unreasonable in their
behavior
with a lot of other groups when they
start making threats against a young
woman who's giving a speech to college
usually you say oh it's such BS who
cares keyboard Warriors they're not
going to do anything they'll come to
their senses before they do anything
crazy
unless the group is defined specifically
by its lack of reasonableness
specifically by a defect in their their
reason this is why the libs
are leaning so hard on the transgender
mob right now
there are other reasons why the libs
have pushed the transgender ideology but
one of the reasons that they're leaning
so hard on the transgender mob is
because they lean on all sorts of groups
to go do their dirty work for them and
to use violence in the streets and then
what they do is they elect prosecutors
to just let their militia Wing off the
hook
but one of the reasons that they're
they're leaning so hard on the
transgender group right now is because
it is it is unreasonable by definition
and so when those threats come in you
have to take them a little more
seriously because unreasonable people
cannot be counted on to come to their
reason now what what did San Francisco
State do about this you know what they
did
they issued an apology letter
to the protesters this is they did the
same thing when I was attacked luckily I
was only attacked with a squirt gun full
of whatever weird liquids were in its
work on it was also on the transgender
issue when years ago before the
transgender thing really became the big
national issue that it is this is back
in 2017 2018 or something I gave a
speech called men are not women and
other uncomfortable truths and the
chancellor of the school wrote an
apology letter that I was invited in the
first place well here you had dear San
Francisco State Community today San
Francisco State finds itself again at
the center of a national discussion
regarding freedom of speech and
expression let me Begin by clearly
saying the trans Community is welcome
and belongs at San Francisco State not
the poor young woman who was violently
attacked and sent running into a room
barricaded for three hours no no the mob
we want you to know your mob is welcome
here thank you to our students who
participated peacefully in Thursday
evening's event peacefully they knocked
this poor woman's clock they chased her
battered into a room
hulking dudes beat up a woman a young
woman at a speech for speaking chased
her into a room and the VP of student
affairs at San Francisco State says
thank you
to our students who participated
peacefully and Thursday evening's event
I'm so proud I'm proud of the moments
when our students demonstrated the value
of free speech and the right to protest
peacefully they didn't protest
peacefully
they beat up a young woman
It's because according to the libs who
have the political power conservative
speech is violence
and leftist violence is speech and
that's just what they mean
so we can whine about the hypocrisy we
can whine about the double standard or
we can
go in let our guys off the hook who have
been prosecuted unjustly and throw their
people who have not been prosecuted
unjustly who have unjustly not been
prosecuted and we can throw them in the
Clank and we can tell the police to do
their jobs and we can give the police
the freedom to do their jobs and we can
tell the lawmakers and the legislators
kick out the miscreants who are
upsetting the whole system and we can
say no to ideologies that are patently
false and we can make certain exclusions
from society and we can come to certain
conclusions and we can say you know we
know we might keep an open mind about a
lot of things but we know that men are
not women and if you say that men are
women then you belong in a classroom to
learn the truth where you belong in a
mad house to learn the truth a little
bit more forcefully but we are not going
to let you guys
violently
upend our whole society
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Sean Hurley who says to think
Jack Daniels used to be the drink of
Outlaw biker gangs
and now now it's the drink of drag
queens and it's actually they could have
the same kind of image it's just
previously it was the drink of you know
Hells Angels and now it's the drink of
the biker from the Village People so
it's all it's definitely a little bit of
a different aesthetic but
it's variations on a theme that's true
and if the transgender activists remain
as violent as they are then
Jack Daniels is going to be appealing to
a group that is no less violent than
they used to actually a lot more violent
a lot more violent
how do we deal with this stuff
I think a real key here
is we've got to be
the reasonable ones
okay
being reasonable doesn't mean being
conciliatory
it does doesn't mean rolling over quite
the opposite when you are reasonable
when you have a clear vision of true and
false and right and wrong
you you can be very effective you can be
very forceful there's no ambiguity
there's no meat in the middle there's no
well should we trans the six-year-olds
or the nine-year-olds there's none of
that it's just no okay we can know that
something is true and we know that this
other thing is false and so everybody
agrees with us on that
the majority of Americans know
transgenderism is insane and so it's the
majority of Americans know
transgenderism is not true and actually
the numbers are moving more in our
Direction More in the direction of Truth
than in the direction of falsehood so
what the libs want us to do is to seem
like we're screaming and angry and crazy
and unreasonable but no
we're not filled with hate we're not
phobic we don't want to genocide anybody
we're just telling the truth as
everybody knows it to be the truth which
is that men and women are not the same
that's very powerful they want to
trigger us
into an unreasonable reaction we
shouldn't give that in reason is on our
side here
you see this in one instantiation of the
weird sex Wars going on you see this
with the push to put porn into
Elementary Middle School classrooms
and libraries so there is a parent in
Texas or I'm sorry in Upstate New York
this is a parent the Pittsford schools
Barker Road Middle School
he shows up he gives a master class in
how to present this issue to the public
and he did it at a school board meeting
let's try another scenario
it's your daughter's 15th birthday party
with a group of her friends and family
gathered around
are you going to give her a copy of girl
in Translation and maybe read a little
bit from it to the group
I'd never been naked with a man before
and Matt's skin felt warm and rough
he must have taken care of the condom
somehow and then suddenly he was inside
me
I gasped but it hadn't hurt as much as
I'd expected it to and then I couldn't
think at all anymore
when he finally
he started to cry again I held him
tenderly in my arms we lay there
together both breathing hard returning
to ourselves
your reaction tells me that you would
not give this book to your daughter
then why is it assigned to 15 year old
10th graders
I've included in your handouts a
printout of a page from the U.S
department of Justice's website that
discusses obscenity
in it it states the following
federal law strictly prohibits the
distribution of obscene matter to minors
to put a pause here and you see how
this guy's monotonous voice is actually
helping his argument here
this guy's level of cool and calm is
really helping his argument it's
disarming it's none of the school board
members are yelling at him sometimes in
these school board showdowns when the
parents get really fired up that gives
the school board members an opening to
say hey stop it calm down don't say it
but he's just
he is presenting himself as the most
boring guy in the world to Great
rhetorical effect and he's just saying
Hey listen simple scenario you're 15
year old because this particular book is
being taught in 10th grade in 15 year
olds at a birthday party would you want
her reading this book and he just reads
it and he doesn't even have that much
emphasis on there he just says this is a
chapter would you want your kid reading
that no probably not
but then
he anticipates the next question says
well what are we supposed to do about it
we can't ban books that would be
terrible the Liberals tell us that
banning books is the worst thing in the
world he says
here's what federal law says about
obscenity
the content that I've just read to you
is obviously obscene and pornographic
how do you scientifically figure out
what's obscene and what's art well
there's no scientific process but come
on let's be real we all know it when we
see it
so you know that this is pornographic
you know that this is obscene you know
it's up to the political community and
the Democracy to come up with standards
for this we all agree on those standards
I've just gotten you to agree with that
by implicitly saying yeah you would want
your kid reading in at a birthday party
okay so here's what the federal law says
about it here's here's why you are
allowed to ban this book but then he
takes his argument one step further any
transfer or attempt to transfer such
material to a minor under the age of 16
including over the Internet is
punishable under federal law
it appears that the members of the board
the supervisor some of the teachers and
some of the Librarians may be guilty of
trafficking and pornography to our
children
I point this out because if you're not
interested in taking care of our
children by not providing them with
pornography maybe you'd be interested in
Saving yourselves from serious legal
action that might land you behind bars
or at a minimum expose you to an awful
lot of public attention for your role in
this child abuse
I suggest you read this handout in its
entirety and not ignore it it might be a
very good starting point for the
discussion you should have with your
attorneys
love it there it is
he starts out
he says hey let's be reasonable let's
just level with each other here I'm not
showboating I'm clearly not show buddy
I'm getting a very monotone reserved
speech
let's be real you know this book is
wrong you wouldn't want your kids
reading it
now I'm going to point to the law to
show you how maybe you were confused I'm
going to give you the benefit of the
doubt maybe you didn't realize that you
have this power This legal power to
proscribe this book and other obscenity
okay so I'm giving you that benefit of
the doubt
but
if you won't listen to reason
here is the threat
the consequence of that law is that if
you guys keep this book in the classroom
you might very well be guilty of
Distributing obscene material to minors
and maybe we've got the political power
in our state maybe we don't in at the
state level in New York we don't
in the local level maybe they do Upstate
New York is pretty conservative
you are opening yourself up to legal
action from us we are not going to just
suggest meekly that you do the right
thing if you don't do the right thing
we're going to prosecute you
we're going to bring the law down we're
going to wield the political power
against you so maybe you ought to think
twice about it that's the way to do it
had it's it's almost the perfect speech
on this issue
it's the best one I've heard yet this
should be taught in conservative oratory
and rhetoric and statecraft classes
this and the politicians should follow
through on this
because the rhetoric is not going to
have any Force
if we don't follow through if we don't
start Prosecuting people under these
laws if we don't start kicking out the
legislators who undermine the
legislature
if we don't start subpoenaing the
corrupt prosecutors who are trying to
undo our political system by going after
the leader of the political opposition
who happens to be a former president
it's not going to have any effect if we
don't do it it's just all going to be
talk and talk is very cheap
got default if we don't start pardoning
the political prisoners
who the current regime arrests unjustly
and if we don't start Prosecuting the
criminals
who are the cause of a lot of these
problems in the first place beautiful
beautiful speech I hope
the libs
you get the message
and I hope conservatives get the message
we don't need to be unreasonable we
don't need to take the bait
reason is on our side
don't see that territory to the lips
reason is on our side and then when you
come to certain conclusions through the
use of your intellect that is when you
can use your will
to bring those conclusions to bear in
public life
and that means promoting good things
and eradicating bad ideas
now unfortunately in our current culture
we're getting the opposite so we just
had Easter
it was I had a lovely Easter I hope you
all had a lovely Easter
Easter weekend is when Walter Reed
the government Hospital
decides to kick Catholic priests
out of the hospital
uh
because they don't want priests in there
getting the good news out even on Easter
week I wish there were some
more con complicated issue going on here
there's nothing more complicated the
Biden Administration like the Obama
Administration just hates Christianity
and hates the representatives of
Christianity so Obama while Biden's vice
president sues nuns for being nuns and
the Biden Administration is now kicking
Catholic priests out of the Walter Reed
hospital
government sent a cease and desist to
these Catholic priests the order was
issued uh because it said no we've got
we've got other pastoral ministers
coming in we're not going to let you
Catholics in anymore
the administration is just hostile to
Christianity it's amazing we look over
at China we say China suppresses
Christianity yeah it does
but before you accuse someone else maybe
you ought to take a look in the mirror
those terrible Nations on Earth are
suppressing Christianity what about our
country Sue's nuns tells Christians they
can't go to their Church during covid
for years when the Christians can go to
the the church the feds send federal
agents in to infiltrate the churches
to spy on the Christians and now says
that the priests can't go talk to sick
people to administer one of the most
important sacraments of the church which
is Extreme unction last rites
that's the state of things okay and so
we've got to come to certain conclusions
about that
and it can't just be well anybody can
come in they're going to send drag
queens into your kids kindergarten class
but they're not going to allow priests
to go in and give the sacraments to sick
people
that's where we are that's how flipped
the society is
so are we are we willing
we are the reasonable ones here we know
everyone knows that's unreasonable
because are we willing to stand by our
conclusions and then enforce those
conclusions with the law I am
Tennessee legislators are
uh so Jim Jordan is
are you
are you I hope so rest of the show
continues now it's music Monday baby you
don't want to miss it it's dailywire.com
codenols at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans we will see what the
membrane segmentum
[Music]
foreign